retour à 1 2
en outre
[Musique]
l'approbation du cadre égalitaire
que font-ils
parfait nous sommes une famille reconnue
devant la loi désormais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et historique parce que nous sommes le premier pays
l'Amérique centrale qui reconnaît le
couples le droit de se marier
les couples de même sexe qui manifestement
nous vivons dans une démocratie et le
les gens peuvent être en désaccord
contre est valable il fait partie du système
démocratique cependant ce quoi
nous demandons ce que nous demandons est quelque chose
respect de base
[Musique]
Yo
quand nous dans la nouvelle république
nous sommes scandalisés par la façon dont
cette autorisation a été traitée pour la
mariage de même sexe
n'ayez pas l'air législatif comme
démocratiquement ça doit l'être mais
donnée pour les durées de vie des résolutions
international que nous respectons
mais nous n'approuvons pas
[Musique]